bonjour il n'y avait pas une vidéo
d'histoire depuis quelques mois sur
cette chaîne times now oblige
alors du coup pour mon grand retour j'ai
décidé de reprendre en douceur par une
gente dame balas une gente dame badass
qui volent amelia erhart est né en 1897
dans une famille du kansas sa famille
déménage souvent pour le travail elle
grandit en partie chez ses grands
parents mais elle et sa soeur ont une
éducation très libre elles font l'école
à la maison elle peut faire des trucs de
garçons comme grimper aux arbres ou
tirer au fusil alors qu'à l'époque le
kansas est plutôt très traditionaliste à
17 ans amelia rentrer au lycée de
chicago la même année la situation
familiale se dégrade sa grand mère
décède son père sombre dans l'alcoolisme
en 1917 elle rend visite à sa soeur qui
vit au canada et elle y travaille comme
aide soignante auprès de soldats
rapatriés
parce que c'est la première guerre
mondiale beaucoup de ces soldats sont
des pilotes qui lui parlent de leur
métier en 1918 elle attrape la grippe
espagnole et profite de sa convalescence
pour apprendre la mécanique son premier
baptême de l'air a lieu tard en 1920
alors ménage avec ses parents en
californie c'est là bas qu'elle visite
un aérodrome avec son père et fait son
premier vol avec un ami elle raconte
plus tard c'est à ce moment là que j'ai
su que je voulais voler la multiplie
alors les petits boulots photographe
chauffeur poids lourd pour s'offrir des
leçons de pilotage son premier court lui
est donnée par anita snook qui est elle
même une pionnière de l'aviation
elle achète son premier avion six mois
plus tard le canari et bat le record
d'altitude féminin en montant à 4300
mètres d'altitude elle reçoit sa licence
de pilote en 1923 est déjà une figure du
milieu
nous sommes en plein dans les années
folles les femmes se modernise coupe les
cheveux travail mais le milieu de
l'aviation reste machiste ce sont
surtout les femmes fortunées qui peuvent
se permettre de voler souvent en
achetant leur propre avion
l'aviation reste aussi une pratique
dangereuse souvent mortels et les crash
lors des meetings aériens sont tellement
fréquent qui font un peu partie du
spectacle en 1927 charles lindbergh
effectué le premier vol au dessus de
l'atlantique sans escale l'année
suivante
amelia est contactée par l'éditeur
georges putman qu'elle est plus par la
suite pour reproduire cet exploit
cependant on ne lui propose pas de
piloter elle d'obtenir le journal de
bord pas les manettes à son arrivée
après 21h de vol elle déclare je n'étais
qu'un bagage un sac de pommes de terre
peut-être qu'un jour j'essayerai seule
sa renommée grandit cependant elle écrit
des articles prend part à des tournées à
travers les états unis pour parler de
ces vols et du rôle des femmes dans
l'aviation
en 1929 elle sont 117 licenciés contre
9000 98 tome on surnomme amelia lady
linn 10 en raison de sa ressemblance
avec lindbergh
mais cela marque aussi son statut de
second rôle féminin le crash de 1929 par
que la fin des années folles mais elle
multiplie alors les campagnes
publicitaires pour pouvoir voler elle
est aussi la première femme à parcourir
seul les états unis en 1928 bat un
nouveau record d'altitude en 1931 en
montant à 5613 m participent à des tas
de concours etc
le 20 mai 1932 elle réalise enfin la
promesse qu'elle s'était faite de
retraverser l'atlantique
seule elle décolle de harbour grâce au
canada en déclarant chers amis proches
comme lointain laissez moi vous dire que
vous allez avoir de mes nouvelles dans
moins de quinze heures elle réussit
effectivement la traversée en 14h56
devenant la première femme à traverser
seul l'atlantique
lorsqu'elle se pose dans un champ de
vache en irlande du nord il aurait
répondu à la question d'où venez-vous
par d'amérique
elle est décorée par le président hoover
et reçoit la légion d'honneur en france
pas mal il est plus facile de traverser
l'atlantique maintenant qu'il ya
quelques années je compte bien leur
faire peut-être pas en solitaire mais
dans un vol transatlantique réguler ce
qui se produira certainement à l'avenir
son action était également féministe en
amelia co fonde une association de
femmes pilotes les ninety nine ce qui
leur permet de se constituer un réseau
et d'obtenir des bourses
elle lance également une ligne de
vêtements fonctionnels et confortables
pour les femmes qui travaillent sa vie
personnelle est aussi avant gardiste
elle finit par accepter les demandes en
mariage de georges putman mais tient à
conserver son nom son autonomie et son
indépendance financière de toutes les
inventions modernes
celle qui bien sûr m'intéresse le plus
c'est le transport aérien voler est sans
doute la réussite scientifique la plus
spectaculaire en l'espace de trente ans
seulement le monde a vu le rêve des
inventeurs devenir une réalité de tous
les jours je suis peut-être partial mais
pour moi aucun autre progrès ne peut
apporter autant de romantisme de beauté
et en même temps d'utilité que de l'oeuf
et l'aviation
moi même je vole avec des moteurs à
explosion masse ce qui m'a emmené au
dessus de l'atlantique nord une partie
du pacifique mexico est très souvent à
travers ce continent
l'aviation géant jeune et moderne ouvre
la voie de ce que peut être la relation
des femmes à la science bien que les
femmes on n'est pas encore tiré tous les
bénéfices possibles
l'aviation est aussi valable pour elle
que pour les hommes
en 1935 elle réalise le premier voile en
solitaire entre hawaï et la californie
puis le premier vol entre los angeles et
mexico mais elle vise toujours plus
grand en 1937 elle veut être la première
femme à faire le tour du monde en avion
décidément après jane carrey et nelly
blaye on commence à avoir pas mal de
globe-trotteuse dans ses chroniques
amelia alors 40 ans elle est accompagné
de fred noonan son copilote et voilà
bord de l'electra le voyage commence le
1er juin de miami ensemble ils survolent
l'amérique du sud l'afrique l'inde
l'asie du sud-est et atteignent la
nouvelle guinée le 29 juin c'est l'une
de leur dernière étape est la plus
difficile
il n'est pas possible de rallier
directement hawaï depuis la nouvelle
guinée ils doivent donc faire une étape
sur l'île hollande une minuscule île au
milieu du pacifique acp 4734 kilomètres
de là un avis khalid askri les attend
sur place pour assurer la liaison radio
et les aider à localiser l'île et se
poser il décolle le 2 juillet le temps
se gâte rapidement la visibilité diminue
de plus cette étape était mal organisé
amelia et noonan étaient fatigués ils
souffraient tous de 10 entre y est ils
avaient laissé à terre leur code morse
une fusée de détresse et leurs antennes
radio pour alléger l'appareil pas super
malin ils ne parviennent pas à trouver
lille mérite à ce cap qui parvient
cependant à capter leur message nous
devrions être au dessus de vous mais
nous ne nous voyons pas le carburant
commence à baisser
nous vous entendons mais n'arrivons pas
à relever un minimum s'il vous plaît
faites un relèvement pour nous et
répondait sur 31 05 en phonie cage à qq
à itasca nous sommes sur la droite 157
337 nous répéterons ce message sur six
mille deux cent dix kilos cycle
attendait nous cherchons vers le nord et
vers le sud puis les messages s'arrête
dès le matin du 3 juillet des recherches
sont entreprises par l'état ce qu'appuie
par des navires et avions lancé par le
président roosevelt dont amélie a été
proche durant deux semaines ils
sillonnent le secteur mais ne
parviennent pas à retrouver l'avion à
partir de là les théories se multiplient
camélia aurait été une espionne capturé
par les japonais
elle aurait atterri sur une autre île en
1940 des ossements et un sextant sont
retrouvés sur l'île denis kumar oro ils
ont été perdus depuis mai les eaux
semblait appartenir à une femme de la
taille d'amelia on ne saura probablement
jamais ce qui s'est passé exactement
mais ces ossements plus quelques
messages radio capter entre les 2 et 7
juillet 1937 semble indiquer que
l'avion a bien atterri sur l'île denis
kumar oraux et que ses deux passagers
ayant survécu quelques temps les appels
à l'aide s'ils viennent bien deux
racontent leurs derniers jours l'avion
est en panne sur une île non reprise sur
une carte petit inhabitée toujours
vivante
il faut se dépêcher dit à mon mari que
ça va on est envahi par l'eau mon
navigateur est gravement blessé nous
avons besoin de soins et nous avons
besoin d aide ne tiendront plus très
longtemps
amélie a été réaliste sur les dangers de
sa passion si elle disait volés just for
fun
elle déclare aussi dans une lettre à son
mari sache que je suis tout à fait au
courant des dangers
je veux le faire parce que j'en ai envie
les femmes doivent tenter des choses
comme les hommes avant tél en cas
d'échec cela doit devenir un défi pour
les autres il faut attendre 1967 pour
que géraldine bloch une autre aviatrice
américaines réussissent le tour du monde
tenter par un média